hey it's guys my name is chana welcome
to a weekly update type video and it's
been like a year probably since I did
the last weekly update so you know what
we're gonna drop the the weekly and just
call this normal update because I
haven't really made a video in a really
long time um and I just wanted to update
you guys with what's going to happen
over the next few weeks hopefully so I'm
in Germany right now might be able to
tell probably not actually because it
you know it doesn't really look like
Germany but i'm just going to show you
guys around so this is what it looks
like i'm actually um in a little village
kind of called kid KEH l it's
essentially about one kilometer away
from strasbourg which is in France and
you can see that may be that that bridge
there is like a foot bridge that
essentially just divides France from
Germany so pretty cool pretty cool but
um I'll be staying here for the next six
weeks pretty much and I've already been
here for two weeks I've like a total
weeks of just north of holidays i
finished my exams for university for the
previous semester and here i am having a
nice little vacation or holiday inn in
germany so yeah that being said though
let's talk about my youtube channel
because i feel like i've been neglecting
it for what is probably a little my arm
here for what is probably um close to
like a year i think i just haven't
really been paying too much attention on
that been involved in a lot of other
projects that have just taken up so much
of my time I'm actually making a game
right now as well quite a serious game
that's a topic for another video
probably but um that's been taking on
piece of time as you can imagine i've
been teaching you guys privately that's
been taking up a lot of time as well but
hey I mean that's just pretty much pure
fun for me um well so I've been doing
obviously university and you know stuff
like that but um now I've got this
chance to essentially spend a bit little
bit more time on YouTube and then take
this kind of pledge that I bit that I do
all the time to be like I'm just going
to actually spend more time on YouTube
now but I am um because of a lot of time
and I just wanted to talk to you guys
about a few things that are going to be
essentially coming to my channel in the
next few weeks so first of all first of
all armed I want to talk to you guys
about how I see the game programming
series ok I've said this so many times
before in live streams but I know that
not all of you obviously catch hm
real live stream so a lot of you you
know a few of you would have heard this
before um but not all of you write a few
hundred of you probably know about this
but not all of you so I thought that I
put this in a video as well and that is
that the way that I teach the game
programming series is sort of like a um
sort of like a ongoing kind of series
that will legitimately go on for as long
as my channel is is alive essentially
right so basically there's no real end
to this series it's kind of like um I
don't know kind of like minecraft i
guess like you this does not end to that
game really i know there is technically
but that's not the point the point is
that series is going to continue because
there's an infinite amount of features
we can add to that game right now I'm
going to keep adding them its gonna be
like my general series if that makes any
sense right so what I was thinking is a
lot of you guys will essentially that
series will never end in in in a sense
right so not so you guys won't be able
to see what it takes to make it came
from start to finish ever right because
there's no series on my channel that
actually does that right now so I
thought a while back and I tweeted the
south and make sure you guys follow me
on Twitter to whatever come fall start
to turn on facebook as well funcom fall
/ the china but um I did post on those
two sides and I said I just had an idea
one time what if I made a series like a
short kind of game right um essentially
the game that I was thinking of making
was flappy bird because I had made that
in a lecture I was really bought in the
lecture and it took me about three hours
but I made the not obviously over a few
lectures I made the game essentially was
really really easy to make and and I
thought that'd be a cool little thing
for me to to put in but then and I
talked about a nice you guys if you were
interested in seeing such series you all
said yes like all of you said yes um and
I'm gonna make it but that was about
three months ago flappy bird is kind of
dead down as in like they're really just
that you know those are hot on flappy
bird or any um you guys still seem to
want the series but there's no flappy
bird anymore so I'm thinking maybe you
know it's probably not in my best
interest to actually make that series
because like that's going dead now um ah
but what i thought i might do anyway was
make that series but some make it using
a
GL right and specifically like OpenGL
for kind of modern up and she'll not the
fixed pipeline functionality kind of
crap that was 90 97 style legacy opened
jail but actually you know modern like
2014 kind of opengl 4.4 4.0 plus you
know that kind of thing and and sort of
have that series as an overview of
OpenGL so it wouldn't really be like and
I be using lwjgl of course for that and
doing it in Java just cuz it's a bit
quicker to develop in and actually
focuses more on the game development or
the language mechanics which is the case
with um surplus of course but I thought
I just do that Ryan and but not really
teach you guys OpenGL in in that series
and not really go really deep into what
I'm doing because it is a its kind it's
quite complicated and beer will detract
from the series but sort of just have it
as an overview of New York for which I
could then later teach to you guys and
dedicated series of something like the
our dinner I'm just discussing this
stuff with you guys right now but some
that was a plan right so I still might
do that depends on what you guys
basically put in the comments on this
video but that's probably gonna happen
right flappy bird in OpenGL four ish and
that would be a really high quality
series so it's going to be properly
edited and stuff it's not going to be
like a live kind of series which is what
game programming is because i don't i
know i don't cut on that I don't stop
the phone I just the camera I don't do
anything i just statically like
recording so yeah anyway that being said
the second series that I'm probably
thinking of doing is actually just a
Java series right a lot of people always
ask me for easels to learn java I always
points you in different directions
depending on what the question is
sometimes I tell well a lot of you are
actually currently learning java for me
in terms of private tutorials but i know
that not all of you guys can afford to
pay for deals now and I respect that
obviously so if you if you can't so
because of that i was thinking of
actually just making a series in which i
teach you guys essentially job right in
a very well edited kind of put together
high quality put high production value
kind of series so that was the other
plan right um
and I i'm probably going to do that like
as well so i'm thinking of those two
series kind of having them concurrently
obviously i'll continue game programming
that's like a life of the channel kind
of series that i just explained which
brings me to my last point and that is
thready game programming one probably a
word that i haven't actually said on
youtube in about two years but 3d game
and roaming is very delicate subject I'm
discusses on many live streams I'm
finally starting to actually put it on
YouTube though my thoughts that is not
the series but essentially I'm at a
crossroads as as to what to do with that
series i actually just can't I can't
side literally but I think I've actually
come to a decision um to be continued no
I'm kidding um but I've actually I think
I think what I'm gonna do with that
series there's a problem with that
series right and that is the fact that
when I started that series that was a
serious out of my channel now I actually
started that series in 2011 october i
think it was i know that the actual
youtube upload date says that it was
uploaded in 2012 I don't know I don't
even know what like februari or march or
april something but um those episodes
were actually first released on youtube
in 2011 ok and if you actually click on
the description i think it says on the
show when the release date was because
those are re uploads i had a previous
channel before and i switch to this
channel which is the journal project in
2012 so which is um yeah i mean i wasn't
only had like fifteen hundred
subscribers on the old channel something
so it wasn't it was a huge or anything
but some i just wish to this one thus
being that being said all I'm saying all
this is because as it is really old like
2011 rise when I started that series and
the problem with that series is that
because it was so old I didn't I
obviously did not know as much as I do
now and some of the stuff I saying that
is just wrong it's just plain Rock just
incorrect right so if I brought back 3d
and programming obviously for the
majority of you because I started I
stopped 32 game programming series when
I had about 3,000 subscribers on this
channel essentially even less right so
to the 27 or so thousand of you who have
subscribed since then
um i have to tell you guys to go and
watch the first episodes obviously catch
up I don't have to do that but I don't
want to tell you guys to watch something
that is incorrect and I know it's
incorrect so why would I tell you guys
to watch that but you have to in order
to catch up to this car in episode
essentially so that's the problem that
I'm actually facing if I decided to
bring back 3d game programming so what
I've decided to do i think the other arm
sorry let me just say one other thing
yella the other option was to this
recording yes good um I hope I'm in
focus and stuff cuz uh oh god I'm better
be in focus anyway because I've been
talking about tennis anyway point is the
other option was to abandon the series
inside started again from scratch right
and basically replaced the old episodes
with new episodes that are 2014 up today
kind of current episodes arm and
actually explain things correctly but
that's not good either because those
episodes have a lot of views obviously
they're a good kind of representation of
my channel in a way even though I'm
wrong and I which they weren't but they
are and that's not my choice
unfortunately but the point is um you
know i'm potentially just losing out on
along a lot of both the history of my
channel and kind of a lot of traffic
sources as well if i get rid of those
videos and so I don't want to do that
obviously um so what I think I've
decided is a bit of both right um what i
will do is i will start 3d game
programming i'll continue the three game
programming series and make it more of
like a sandbox overview almost like game
programming but i don't want to turn it
too much into game programming so it
will probably end eventually and then so
it'll be it'll continue being the same
format it is where I now assumed out
really far you can see my whole screen
basically you know you have to actually
watch them full screen and if you like
50 minute to 60 minute and one we got
one hour long episodes all that stuff
and then what I will do is start a new
series we're going to be a 3d a very
in-depth series which will actually
restart the series don't do it from the
beginning and explain everything why I
like explain everything perfectly and
that will be an edit series probably as
well so that's the plan ok I'm gonna
leave you guys to it are there people
coming probably think I'm really weird
here yesterday
do confirmed um but essentially what you
have to watch out for is a flappy bird
in OpenGL for should start airing in
about a week or so I've been preparing
the project of that and a Java learning
java series which will be really well
put together a lot Thorbardin be should
be fantastic all right that's it hope
you guys enjoyed it I'll probably make
more updates because I would just really
like being out here and in this kind of
weather and um because it's summer here
in Germany obviously whereas it's winter
in Australia so here but anyway that's
going to wrap it up at the like button
if you guys enjoyed this video please
leave a comment regarding your thoughts
about what I've just said I mean I want
to be talking to people not I don't know
something else so yeah not just my
little Nexus 5 phone so yeah anyway that
be oh yeah one more thing flappy bird
the fabulous series by the way I did
mention of gel force he probably could
guess it's not OpenGL you know yes but 2
point 0 for mobile devices are going to
be fighting but for desktop essentially
not for um for Android or iOS anyway
that being said I'll see you guys later
i'm heading i'm reaching 30,000
subscribers very soon which is amazing
by the way so that that warrant some bro
time so i'll see you guys um hopefully
rooster